>>>Daniel Friedman: Hello and welcome everyone. It's
December 27, 2022. We're in
active bookstream number 1.03.
We're in the third in a series of
discussions on governing continuous
transformation. Off to you,
Bleu.
>>>BLEU KNIGHT: Okay, so this bookstream is going to
be part of an ongoing series of
bookstreams at the Active Inference
Institute. So please get in touch if you
would like to participate either in one
of these zero contextualization videos
or an upcoming discussion over the
material. And these are all of our links
here. This is a participatory online
lab. We are open to interacting with
anyone, no matter what your level of
expertise is in ants of inference or
governance or other. So the goal of this
bookstream is to discuss chapter three.
We're going to go over the book map and
roadmap and the keywords of the chapter.
And then there's two sections that kind
of fell out of this chapter three. So
we'll split those up so we can
just maybe introduce ourselves. So I'm
Bleu Knight. I'm an independent research
consultant in New Mexico, and I'll pass
to Tyler.
>>>TYLER SULLBERG: How's going? I'm Tyler. I'm more of a
DAO practitioner out of California.
Daniel: I'm Daniel, I'm a researcher in
California. And as this is our year
closing bookstream, and this is going to
be focusing on some board and
strategy related topics, I think it'll
be interesting to talk about reflection
and how do we look back, how do we now
cast, how do we look forward?
Nice. Yes. I'm definitely excited to
align the material that is presented in
the book with the ongoing development of
strategy and governance in Active
Inference Institute. So that's for me
what I'm excited about today.
Okay, so this chapter is Micro
Foundations of Strategic Governance,
and the two sections are The Role of the
Board and Models of Board Cognition.
So, Tyler, do you want to read this
section of the abstract? Sure. Right.
So there is no universal governance
model. The strategic role of the board
does vary as a function of culture,
laws, governance orientation, ownership
structure, and firm context. The period
of 1998 to 2001, time of financial
markets irrational exuberance dominated
by coherence governance orientation
centered around stock price
considerations, has given birth to
today's compliance driven governance
logic ruling public companies. Simply
put, ever since, corporate governance
has been estranging the board that's
uniquely integral part of strategy
process. Coincidentally, during this
very period, management research started
complementing their two demographic
input output models with behavioral and
cognitive dimensions, loping a new
conversation around the cognitive
microfoundations of board effectiveness.
To this day, the study of the board's
strategic role remains confined to the
boardroom increased environment as an
exogenous variable. Bleu will take the
next half. .
The top down cultivated hierarchical
disconnect so characteristic of
traditional corporate governance and
strategy processes is more likely to
fuel prediction error, reinforcing the
perception that the world is
unpredictable and uncertain. Indeed,
the very limitations of corporate
governance research may be an astute
reflection of the very real and often
selfinflicted limitations of the board's
strategic role. Shareholders are
challenged to ensure that the board's
full strategic potential is not wasted.
More specifically, there is a need for a
new self organizing governance logic.
Okay, Tyler, do you want to read this,
the role of the board? Yeah, sure. So
for section here is the role of the
board. And then we'll go into really
different models thinking about board
cognition. So we'll start with this
quote from John there's no universal
governance model. The strategic role of
the board does vary as a function of
culture, laws, governance orientation,
ownership structure, public, private
equity, founder, family led controller,
or combination thereof in firm specific
context. All right, let's go to the next
one. Cool. Yeah. This is upper echelon.
So not being familiar with a lot of
business like vernacular, I just put
this in there. So it's the high level of
command authority or rank. And this can
be like top level management or the
board of directors or both. It seemed
like that it wasn't specifically defined
in the book as we're reading it, but
Tyler, do you have any thoughts on that
specifically? Like, what do you think
Bijan means? My understanding is that it
was a combination of both the board and
the top management structure.
So yeah, he left it pretty big, but
that's my understanding.
All right, so we'll start off talking
about what a board could be. And so this
is Bajan's definition of what a board
could mean and not necessarily what it
does mean. So the board of directors is
a unique, integral part of the firm's
upper echelon. It acts from within and
without the firm as a boundary spanner.
It should encapsulate strategy,
processes, constructive attention
between organization and active
environment, exploitation and
exploration, as well as financial and
strategic controls. And so I think even
people outside of like an active
inference free energy governance context
would probably agree with roughly this
definition, that a board should be this
collective governing body that used
their collective wisdom. Because the
idea is that is greater than just like,
one person at the top making all the
decisions and that collective wisdom,
something interesting and unique comes
out of that. That's not necessarily what
always happens. Oftentimes it's not
exactly what happens. So let's go to the
next slide. We talk about different,
these are different ways of thinking
about how a board actually functions.
And there's like a lot of different ways
like the board's
role in what they actually do and
organization varies considerably across
a lot of exafferent dimension. So one
different way you could look at it is
the cultural background of the board.
So this is from a study, I think they
did this on Dutch Royal Company, which
had branches both in England and then
also in the Rhine in like Germany.
Right? And so they found that top
managers having the English Sachs and
corporate governance orientation are
more likely to pursue exploitative and
external growth strategic renewal
trajectories, while those having a Ryan
corporate governance orientation are
more likely to pursue exploratory,
internal growth strategic renewal
trajectories. So I think what they're
implication saying is that they're
facing similar strategic concepts,
they're the same company, but for some
reason culturally they're more oriented
to doing certain kinds of actions. Then
you can also think about it just by the
context of the business, right? There
might be certain boards that have
different roles that are more
appropriate for certain kinds of
contexts. So it might be more
administrative. Maybe it's kind of like
a legal requirement to have the board.
And that's kind of why they're there.
They're more of just making sure that
everything is running on time, more of
an entrepreneurial where they're
actually taking more strategic role.
There's directing and controlling. We
can imagine that they're more kind of
integrated with management and then
there's supervisor, which might just be,
hey, making sure that everything is
going okay, that there are no outrageous
frauds being committed within the
company. Though a very common issue too,
is that the board often doesn't have
much of a role at all. And so this is a
quote from one of the studies that the
John cites that managerial hedging money
theory argues that boards are legal
fiction dominated by management. So the
idea here is that management actually
runs the show. You have a board, they
have to check some boxes. They're often
legally mandated, right? So, like, for a
501 or a C Corp, you have to
have a board. But they're like, okay,
let's just appease regulators and have
this board. We're not actually giving
them anything substantial to do. This is
actually like a really big problem in
nonprofit board management as well,
because it's very unclear what nonprofit
boards are supposed to do. And
oftentimes nonprofits will put a lot of
donors on their board in a long way just
to appease these donors egos in
chance for getting more funding, but
without having a clear sense of what
they're actually supposed to do. This
actually matters quite a lot because
they don't know what they're supposed to
do. But they have all the power in the
organization, like the board runs the
organization in a nonprofit, and so they
have unknown accountability, unclear
responsibilities, but all the power.
And so what that often dissolves into is
that the CEO or the executive director
is actually running the show and the
board is there just kind of like
checking boxes and more of a formality,
which does not really get as a greater
cognition that the genre is hinting at.
It could be possible by having a board.
So that's unfortunate. Let's get to the
next one. All right.
Okay, so this was
the first of John's claims. There is a
danger, however, that the compliant
board is breathing formalism group think
and risk aversion at the expense of the
operational understanding strategic
focus and independent thinking.
Effectively, the board has been
distanced from initiating and directing
strategic renewal. Unless lawmakers
evolve corporate governance guidelines
in tune with the requirements of a
distributed continuum world, the board
is either relegated to strategic
relevance or increasingly represents a
force of inertia reflected on the
struggle with growing complexity.
All right, so let's just unpack
what the Dean meant by irrational
exuberance from that claim. So,
irrational exuberance, this is a famous
quote from Alan Greenspan and this was
from the 1996 when this was like the
beginning of the.com boom. the.com boom
still had a couple of years left to go
before it really kind of petered out.
They said irrational duprance has unduly
escalated asset values. And so during
this period it was like the late ninety
s, you had all these companies that,
well one, there's like wild speculation
in these companies, but also there
wasn't great strategic or financial
controls by the boards. And so you had
companies like Enron and Tyco WorldCom
that were very much misrepresenting
their financials. And so the end result
of this, after the bus, the.com bust,
was the Sarbanes of the ant.
I always mispronounce this sarbanes
offway act. So which,
what that did was that it created the
number of like audit and regulatory
controls, especially over the board,
make sure the board have conflicts of
interest, that they're actually
overseeing the organization effectively,
which is all wonderful in many ways that
can be great, those are good things.
But there's also a ton of regulation
that imposes on these companies and it
also imposes a certain model of what a
board is supposed to be doing onto these
corporations. And so John does not
like some aspects of that, some of the
way that enforces what a board can and
should be. And so he says the 2002
Sarbanes Oscillate Act, the United
States has been the most prominent lit
state of product resulting from
irrational exuberance, imposing
draconian measures on the audit and
financial representations of publicly
listed companies. So I
think what level of John is saying about
this period is that like before 2002 for
Sarbanes Oxley, you had a lot of
misrepresentations, a lot of rational
exuberance. But something interesting
that did happen during that same period
was that you also had a lot of
experimentation on what a board could
and should be. And so you agent a lot of
research during the same time thinking
about what managerial cognition, what
board cognition actually looks like,
what the board's role could be. And that
kind of free and loose culture also
created a more expansive view of what
a board is. But then once you get into
2002 and you get all these regulations
from Starbanes Oxley that really
constrained the idea of what a board
could be and put all of these other
burdens on top of the board and so it
really kind of diminished their
potential strategic and cognitive role
within the company. Bleu Daniel,
do you have anything you just want to
add here?
All right, so that was talking about the
role of the board and that's all. Just
to say, the role of the board is often
extremely unclear, like any nonprofit or
corporation. And so now the John's
kind of switches gears and says, okay,
well, let's think about different models
of board cognition and different ways
that you can think about Hohwy a board
could operate. So let's go to the next
one. Bleu sure.
So Rendova 1999 was among the
first to link managerial cognition to
corporate governance, distilling the
board's distinct cognitive contribution
to strategy process, specifically in
terms of environmental scanning and
interpretation. Her contribution can be
considered seminal laying grounds for a
stewardship inspired corporate coherence
approach that is now widely adopted by
leading private equity firms where top
management team and board strategize
together, often in highly complementary
ways and based upon cash finance equity
centric alignment of interest as opposed
to free call options. Private equity is
more of a governance than a financing
model explaining its public market
equivalent outperformance. According to
Rendova, board directors do impact
decisions. And so
I thought that this idea of managerial
cognition was interesting. It just
speaks to my interest in hierarchical
cognition ant different levels. So this
is a reference that Bijan gives,
that is the managerial response to
changing environments perspectives on
problem sensing from social cognition.
So looking at like, what is managerial
cognition? So this paper characterizes
managerial problem sensing and necessary
precondition for managerial activity
directed towards organizational
adaptation as composed of noticing,
interpreting and incorporating stimuli.
And I liked this definition of cognition
really as like noticing, interpreting
and incorporating stimuli. Although in
the paper they don't say managerial
cognition directly, I think that it's
attributed largely to this paper as very
seminal in the field and then
environmental scanning and
interpretation from the previous claim.
Also, so this is the Rendova paper that
Bijan cited and it says the cognitive
perspective in this paper proposes
suggests that directors contribute to
dealing with the complexity and
uncertainty associated with strategic
decisions. It argues that directors
possess valuable problem solving
expertise which they can apply to a
variety of contexts. Directors make
their cognitive contributions to
strategic decision making by performing
along with the firm's managers a set of
cognitive tasks scanning,
interpretation and choice. And like, I
noticed again this like environmental
scanning, interpretation and choice,
how does this relate to noticing,
interpreting and incorporating stimuli?
It's like a rephrase scanning,
interpretation and choice.
Okay. And so another claim that
Bishop makes in the paper, he says
Rendova appreciates the dynamic nature
of strategy process when she postulates
that board participation in strategic
decision making rises with increasing
environment complexity and uncertainty.
However, Rendova's approach is rather
static as it falls short of connecting
the board table to the rest of the
organization and interchangeably treats
perception as interpretation. A free
energy governance lens instantly exposes
the obvious shortcomings maybe Tyler's
going to tell us how. All right,
so let's go through a couple more of
these different models of board
cognition. One of them is called
Stewardship Theory. To look quote here
from one of the original papers about
stewardship theory, Davis 2007. So
economic approaches to governance, such
as agency theory tend to assume some
form of homo economicness which depicts
subordinates as individualistic,
opportunistic and self serving.
Alternatively, sociological and
psychological approaches to governance,
such as stewardship theory, depicts
subordinates as connectivity, pro,
organizational and trustworthy. And so
there's, I think, a couple of different
lenses you can think about stewardship
theory. One is kind of more of this like
communist version of a more collectivist
world where actually we're not all fully
selfish, we also have collectivist
aims and people. It's like a
different way of thinking about
individual motivation. I think another
one too is that where this has really
shined and become actually important in
applied practice has been in private
equity. And so in private equity, the
owners are the same as the management.
And this actually ends up mattering
because what they seem to be safe down
this quote here is that actually impacts
performance quite a bit,
I think. Sorry, we already read that
quote. But the idea here is that when
management ownership are combined, the
management acts as more stewards rather
than people who are just paper pushers,
but they're actually really taking care
of this investment. And Jorge aligned
with the board interests.
The next one is absorbative capacity.
So Absorbing Capacity thinks about the
board as a a cognition unit that's
informed by the experiences of its
members. So similar to what Bleu said
earlier, that the board's expertise in
the board's cognition is informed by the
diverse experiences of its board
members. So the ability of a firm to
recognize the value of new external
information assimilated and apply it to
commercial ends is critical in its
innovative capabilities. We labeled this
capability the firm's absorptive
capacity suggests that is largely a
function of the firm's level of prior
related knowledge. It goes on to say
it's from Mendova director's
contribution as a source of requisite
varieties to increase the pool available
interpretive framework on which decision
group which the decision group can draw.
So the idea here is that there's limited
information that any individual or any
group can process. You should get more
people with more diverse experiences,
so you could process more information
through different models and that will
lead to more enhanced cognition. I could
add a note on that previous slide.
The mention of the requisite variety in
the Rendova quote is from Cybernetics
and Ross Ashby's law of requisite
variety, which is the idea that for
a system to be a good regulator adaptive
in a given environment that it needs to
have internal states that are of the
order of magnitude of external states.
Like if there's 100 positions that the
food could be in but you can only
conceptualize of ten, then you're not
going to be able to have a granular or
nuanced enough perspective to find the
food. So that ties
the managerial and strategic practice
oriented areas which frankly dominate
society, to some of the more theoretical
perspectives and system independent
perspectives on cybernetics and
cybernetic systems as cognitive systems,
which is what brings this entire
discourse into the active inference
area. And I think that's also another
important lens, I'll think about Noor
diversity because a lot of times Noor
diversity is often seen through more of
a political lens when there's also like
a computational lens as well. That's
really important.
Cool. Okay, moving on.
Forbes and Milliken's contribution is
relevant in three regards. First, it is
impossible to meaningfully infer board
performance from demographic variables
in the absence of a process model
linking demography and output. Second,
the board's role as a group is
essentially a cognitive role and is
therefore a cognitive rather than
behavioral perspective is critical to
better understand the essence of board
performance. And third, effort norms,
cognitive conflicts and the use of
knowledge and skills are important
process variables underlying board
performance. I think Tyler is going to
tell us effort norms and cognitive
conflicts. All right, so effort norms,
ie. The intensity of cognitive
resourcefulness on the task performance,
behavior, cognitive conflicts, the
leveraging of differences in perspective
and the use of knowledge and skills are
important process variables underlying
board performance. The dimension of
effort norms cannot be stressed enough.
The sheer presence of the collective
pool of competencies and experiences is
rather meaningless unless actively and
purposefully exercised. So the
idea here is that even if you have a
diverse set of perspectives on your
board, and even if you have
computational firepower, theoretically,
if the board isn't actually inclined to
acting on that and processing that
information, it's just not going to
happen. In that power you have that
potential power just doesn't really
matter. I think this is important too,
because a lot of boards see themselves
in a more passive way where the
CEO is feeding them information and kind
of giving them things to rubber stamp
approve. And so even if you have people
who have those capabilities, that
capacity, it's not really even being
used. And so you have to have a board
that's actually inclined to taking more
of an active role to really get that
cognitive potential from your board
members or anything
out there. Yeah. One thought by analogy
to the brain and the central nervous
system is like the usage of
resources for cognition, and the brain
is still using a lot of energy,
slightly less, but a lot during sleep.
So what exactly are these cognitive
conflicts? What is the resource in
the case of the board? Is it the limited
time in a meeting where people can
speak? Is it limited attention to
different decisions? What is it
that's actually conflicted?
And how do we gain insights from
thinking about the board as a cognitive
entity.
So I think we'll get some of those soon
when we talk about inertia. But I think
you're right in that the time, the
limited time constraints are a huge
factor of that, where it's just like
you're less inclined to actually do a
very high cognitive task, a very
demanding cognitive task. You have a
couple of hours every month to really
talk about it. Or in the case of a 501
C, three, like, board members are
unpaid. And so if you're an unpaid
member, there's probably like limited
time you're actually willing to put to
actually thinking about some of these
problems. So I think that there are a
lot of dimensions to it, but we'll talk
about that shortly.
I think this last end of this quote,
the competencies and experiences of the
collective pool is meaningless unless
it's actively and purposely exercised.
Really speaks a lot to collective
intelligence and how, like, within a
company, a board, a managerial system,
there is this collection and you're not
contributing to the emergence
of the group intelligence if
you're not using all of the different
expertise of the different people in the
group. And so I think that it's really
limiting. But but I also wonder,
you know, like, we might have a board
that's like a very diverse group of
people and we all have different tasks
in management, different skills in
management, but we also can do things
like crochet and bake and paint. And so
to what extent are these other skills
that might be present in the board,
like relevant or necessary for
management to thrive and really to
enhance the collective for the group? I
don't know. One last short thought
on that, recalling the earlier quote,
how there's no universal governance
model. It's like if we were talking
about ant colony strategies, is it
better to simply have more nest mates or
fewer or bigger brain per body size or
smaller? It's like there isn't a
universal answer because there's
different strategies, in fact multiple
strategies that might be adaptive in a
given niche, but it doesn't really make
sense to even talk about one without the
other, whether you're talking about like
chess or ant colonies or the board. And
so that's where the particular
partitioning active coherence lab helps
because it reminds us that the cognitive
process of perception cognition,
including action, selection and then
action and action is happening within
the context of a generative process in
the niche. And that can't be just like
left for later. That's an intrinsic part
of the particular partitioning.
Okay, so here Bijan makes the claim that
essentially there are three important
conclusions to take forward from golden
and Zajac 2001. I don't know if
I said that right. Probably not. First,
demographic and procedural variables
impact strategic change, rather curve
linearly. Second, power relationships
are critical to understanding the impel
versus impede debate and strategic
renewal. And third, attention, focus and
agreement in terms of an okacoian
linkage of cognition and structure and
that's in this reference, Ocasio 1997
are a promising venue upon which to
pursue future research. And then
this linkage of cognition and structure
from this paper it's toward an attention
based view of the firm from William
Ocasio here he says the
central argument is that firm behavior
is the result of how firms channel and
distribute the attention of their
decision makers. What decision makers do
depends on what issues and answers they
focus their attention on. What issues
and answers they focus on depends upon
the specific situation and on how the
firm's rules, resources and
relationships distribute various issues,
answers and decision makers into
specific Communications and procedures.
And so that pushes salience, I think to
the forefront, especially with regard to
board collective intelligence, like
maybe the crocheting and knitting and
baking and all those things are not
really relevant. Or maybe they could be.
Maybe this is the explore part where
active coherence comes in.
Another link here with attention and
structure and cognition is attention is
something that's more dynamic but it
requires the structural connections like
between brain regions or at the synaptic
level or APIs that call each other in a
computational system. Those pipes have
to be in place for attention to be
dynamically allocated. And so the
structural aspects of the firm are more
like its morphology and then the
attention and the more rapidly changing
aspects are more like perception and
fast changing cognition. And so that's
going to be like a theme that gets built
upon are the faster changing,
more perceptual and decision making like
components of the firm and the slower
changing, more structural elements of
the firm.
Just to build on. That a little bit like
something I've noticed from Fire
companies that even if you have a very
engaged board, like a board that we say
gives a lot of attention within the firm
and has a high attentional capacity,
they may not actually be linking that to
the structure of the firm. So for
example, something I've often observed
is that you'll have two people putting
together the quarterly board deck for a
company of like 1000 people. So
everything gets processed through this
like tiny funnel of two people who have
to synthesize everything on behalf of
the board where they're essentially just
like making the conclusions for the
board at that point. And so if you're
not really linking both the attention
and the structure you're really missing
out on the potential power of your
board.
All right, inertia. So inertia you
can think of it really as just like
reluctance to change. Similar to the
idea of boundary rationality is that
there are certain constraints which you
have to reason that board often reasons
within. So read a couple of quotes from
Presentation mode.
So I'll read this quote from Hannah
1977. He came up with the original idea
of inertia organizational inertia which
again isn't specific to firms.
It's really an idea that you can apply
to any collective system. So there are a
number of obvious limitations on the
ability of organizations to adapt. That
is, there are a number of processes that
generate structural inertia. And John
says that Andrew Corcoran governance
best practice guidelines may rather fuel
governance inertia rather than treating
the board as an impactful variable
supporting continuous strategic renewal.
And so to make this a little more
concrete, we can kind of go through a
couple of different examples of inertia.
And these all come from Hannah's 2nd 77
paper, where he kind of defined this
idea of organizational inertia. So I'll
list a couple of them. One was that
previously made investments aren't
easily transferable. There are
constraints on the information decision
makers receive. There are political
constraints, there are cost of history
to allocate tasks and create procedures.
So you've basically done all the work to
figure out who's doing what. It's a lot
of work to redo that. There are legal
constraints, perceptions of legitimacy.
If you were to change course at this
point, unclear how your strategy will
succeed in competitive environments,
like if we do this, how will others
react? And so all of this just creates a
sense of anxiety that people just don't
want to confront and they feel good and
comfortable pursuing something that they
already understand. And so you can think
of that as organizational inertia. And
this is particularly a problem with
boards because especially if you have a
board with limited attentional capacity,
they're not going to be putting the time
to really think they're going to work
through that anxiety. They're not going
to be actually doing the hard work to
overcome that. And so you end up kind of
just defaulting to something that people
already understand. And so there's often
something that you hear in organizations
where like, okay, well, we could do this
really ambitious thing, and there are
people who might be actually excited
about this more exploratory initiative
that you could do, but how are we going
to sell that to the board, right? And
oftentimes it's the CEO has to put their
reputation on the line to sell something
that's more exploratory and risky to the
board who has limited attention
capacity. They're anxious about it, so
they just kind of have to trust this one
person to say, yes, go for it, it's
okay. Again, you're not really unlocking
that cognitive power potential of the
board. One more aspect. There on inertia
to connect to the Bayesian physics.
Inertia is something that physical
objects have in classical mechanics,
like whether it's a ball at rest that
requires some force to push or whether
it's a bicycle and movement whose
inertia allows it to stay upright.
Inertia is an aspect of physical
objects. And by analogy, in the
Bayesian Physics, the inertia is like
the resistance of a prior to be updated
to incoming observations. So a prior
distribution with a high inertia, it's
like a heavy. Distribution, it's
immovable to new stimuli and that
corresponds to having low attention
because it's like as new information
comes in, the prior has high inertia,
it doesn't update a lot. Whereas when
there's high attention paid to the
incoming stimuli, in the extreme the
prior just updates to whatever the new
stimuli says. That's our new best
estimate. So that's ultra high attention
and also very moveable.
And that's like a light object.
And so there isn't a general answer.
But this puts us into a framing where we
can think about this structural and
attention inertia as part of the
morphological and dynamical cognitive
process of the board and the
organization more generally.
Yeah, I really like that perspective on
it and it makes me think about how, why
Bijan is spending so much time thinking
about the board. Because it's kind of
this communication of low attention,
high responsibility for updating the
beliefs of the organization. And so
that's where like a lot of any like
continuous change or transformation
would have to happen start the board.
So I understand my Bishop is spending so
much time thinking about this and
talking about different models of board
cognition.
Hopman Ant, Al 2019 make an invaluable
contribution in moving away from
deterministic models that suggest which
specific board configurations and
leadership concentrations enhance board
effectiveness, firm performance and the
firm's overall strategic capability.
Instead, they focus on the board's
better capabilities such as self
evolution and self reconfiguration to
power a continuous strategic renewal.
Right. The board's power of visa visa
management is strongly related to the
board's hair initiates self evaluation
and self reconfiguration, thereby
encoding that the board can still
critically evaluate strategic proposals
and reconfigure strategies. So
unfortunately though, Hopman and Al do
not go far enough. Since strategic
renewal remains balancing by the board
chair, we need governance processes that
neutralize the over dependencies on the
chairman and the CEO. So oftentimes
within an organization that has the
board, the chairman is kind of running
the show on the board and their
counterfactuals is the CEO. And they do
a lot of the agenda setting for how the
board actually operates, how much
attention that they're actually giving
on to problems, the kind of information
that's the incoming and available to the
board. And so a lot of responsibility
relies on the board of like how
cognition can actually happen. And I
have been in this position myself, I've
been a board chair. A lot of
responsibility kind of ends up being on
you for how well the board and
consequently the organization can run.
And so what's unfortunate, and something
I've actually tried to do myself, is
like spread the responsibility of the
board chair throughout the board so that
cognition doesn't rest on like a single
person, but it's actually more spread
out through that entire cognition unit
and that is difficult to do. So I'm
curious if the genre later on in the
book has some recommendations on how to
structure that.
Daniel Bleu, anything to add here?
Yeah, I'm curious, Tyler, with respect
to the Dow world that you live in, what
are some governance processes that do
neutralize that over dependence
on the chairman and CEO of a company?
Can you maybe say a few words about
that? Yeah,
there's a lot of different governance
processes, but I can talk about a couple
of them. So one is that if you're doing
especially like token or token based
voting with the NFCs or C 20s,
generally most people can make a
proposal. Not anyone can make a
proposal, but a lot of times the agenda
setting can be done in a distributed
way. So it's not necessarily the board
chair and the CEO determining, hey,
these are the things that we're bringing
up to a vote, but that can be done more
dynamically. And oftentimes there's a
quorum rules about who can propose. So
it's not like fully decentralized, but
in a sense that agenda setting can be
done more decentralized.
And there's also ways of creating
salience as well without having a
single person at the top saying what is
salient and what matters and what
doesn't. There are different governance
strategies where salience kind of
bubbles up and you can kind of determine
certain governance rules, like your
quorum, for example, in a more dynamic
way. And so there's a lot there of how
it can't work. Then there's also how it
actually works in practice and in
reality. A lot of times with Dow
governance, usually often Heins like a
couple of people making a lot of the
proposals. And so what's interesting is
that even if you want to be in a more
distributed way, sometimes there's this
pull of gravity towards centralized
decision making. And it really just is
that there's limited attention available
even if you're not saying you're not
legally mandating some kind of
centralized structure. There's just like
only a couple of people who are really
willing to actually synthesize all this
information at any given time,
especially within Dows. Dow proposals
are often extremely technical and
there's often limited people who can
even do that if they wanted to. So it's
something that I've been personally
struggling with is thinking about like,
okay, well, there's this world that we
want to live in that's maybe more
decentralized and less hierarchical and
more connected, but there's also just
these constraints on human time and
attention effort capabilities that
constrains the kind of structures that
you can have.
And hopefully later in the book that
John will have some good recommendations
on how you construct your organization,
your board, to kind of mitigate that
pull towards centralized processes. But
it's just something I witnessed a lot in
the data world as well.
Cool, thanks. So I think
that's the end of the material today.
So next week the chapter is quite a bit
longer. This one was pretty short, but
yeah, we're looking forward, I think,
to what Bijan is going to tell us about
free energy governance. And he's setting
the stage now for delineating the
problems. And now how do we go about
solving them? I'm curious to delve into
this next section with you guys.
Can I bring up a few points and
questions? Of course. All right. So one
of them was it described the board as a
spanner earlier on. And I wondered
whether the board was kind of like at
the heart of the onion, insulated by
more and more layers, or whether the
board is on the front line interfacing
more publicly in the actual position,
or that person perhaps serving in a
different position as well, like wearing
multiple hats. So feel free to give any
thoughts on that. Or we can just raise
the point. Yeah, I mean, my
understanding of well, there's like how
it actually works now and then how it
can work, how it actually works now is I
think it's often more like in the onion
where they're getting more refined and
more refined information that filters
through a hierarchy until it finally
gets to the board. And what I think the
gen is hoping for is something that
resembles more of like a motherboard,
this integrating unit where there's all
these connections from other parts of
the organization. There's still that
hierarchical structure but is not
insulated from the rest of the
organization. And I think that's what
Bijan is getting at. But from my
understanding of board governance, that
is less often the case and it's really
hard to build.
So I think that that's like a really
great question and I'd like to really
kind of explore it more in more detail
when we get into our discussion section.
So I think we should add that to the dot
one list.
Another topic is there was
the mention of a compliance board
as well as how a board could be like
dissonant or impel versus impede.
And so how to balance between
simply going with what the body provides
towards totally wishing things were
different. It's like in the extreme,
neither is going to work. So there has
to be some middle path, but there's no
universal model. So that's just kind of
one point and then another one
was the market centrism of
a for profit company means that
in some sense, but please suggest if
otherwise the financial success
on the broader market will
define the persistence and the growth of
the company. So that is kind of like
projecting this very high dimensional
space of strategy and competition and
attention projecting down onto
a number line, like did the stock price
go up or down? And so to
what extent do for
profit and not for profit organizations
or components of organizations have
clearer or more
alignable measures?
It's just like if the only criterion of
cognition was this
one test, then you kind of get the good
heart's law situation where other
measures can fall by the wayside. So how
does that get prevented or ameliorated
in for profit endeavors. And then on the
other side, how does that not get
ignored when there are very real
material constraints in nonprofits as
well? Yes, and I forgot to mention
this point earlier, but it's like a
really important one that a lot of our
model of shareholder governance is often
very culturally specific to America. So
there are other ways you could think
about board governance and corporate
governance. So, for example, especially
in Germany, there's like a stakeholder
governance model where, for example,
you are legally required to have a board
member in Germany who is a
representative of the workers. And so
this is more aligned with like and you
could think of that. You could expand
that model too, of like, stakeholder
governance. That could mean so that's
just Germany's model where they're like,
hey, workers rights need to also be
important in addition to profit. Right,
but you could also expand that to think
of, okay, well, what if we had an
advocate for the consumer on the board,
right? You could expand that idea of
what a for profit company's stakeholder
governance model can look like. In
Japan, for example, there's a lot of for
profit companies are also family run,
so there's these family considerations
on top of the for profit incentives
as well. So then even between
a C Corp. Like for profit company and
then a nonprofit, there are different
legal structures that kind of bridge the
distance between the two. So one of the
famous ones is called a B Corp. And so a
B corp It's essentially the same thing
as C Corp. It can make money. It's a
for profit company, but in the bylaws,
they are not legally mandated to only
maximize for profit. They can also
maximize for other they call it like
double bottom line initiatives. So
there's other things that this for
profit company can try to do aside from
just get money. And then there's a lot
of different permutations of that. Like
a lot of different legal structures can
have that. And same with the nonprofit,
too. Even a nonprofit couldn't have ways
that is trying to get revenue and think
in a more for profit way, even though
there aren't people who are shareholders
who are going to profit from it, but
they can act in a similar way. So I
think often, like, the distinctions
between nonprofit and for profit can
actually become quite fuzzy in the way
that we think about for profit
governance is often very culturally
centric on how we've done things in the
US. And in England, not necessarily on
how it can be done. And as to your
first point, Daniel, I think I'm curious
to know what goes into defining or
creating a compliant board or like a
dissonant board. I would think that it's
not structured to be a compliant board.
I mean, maybe they write it into the
bylaws that the board just agrees with
everything that everyone does. But I
think it's more of like an emergence
property of the board. And does the
entire board need to be replaced? If say
you have a compliant board and you want
more of a strategy driven governing
board, do you have to completely
interrupt the norms? Right? Like Bijan
had said, the norms, if the norm is to
be compliant, do you have to just erase
everyone to bring in a whole new crew to
develop new norms? Otherwise that one
person who's like, oh, let's just go
along with what everybody says. They'll
keep that culture alive, right?
To clarify that, I think what Bijan
meant was compliance board, which is
more like if you're like a regional
regulatory, if you're a nuclear power
plant, for example, you want to have a
compliance centered board who's making
sure that you're following all the rules
and regulations. But I think to your
point, Bleu like a compliance board is
also an important a lot of boards
function as compliant. Boards are just
rubber stamping approvals and that is
not super useful. So yes, I think that's
also a good point. And one fun
topic I think to do a little research
into is how did we even get here with
a board? I mean, isn't a board or the
table that was also mentioned, those are
just like rectangles. How did we get to
this point where the meeting table
architectures and the people gathered
around it have become legally
required and then even subconstrained
from there. And so really, just thinking
broadly, as I think in the Dow
and other spaces, people are thinking
broadly about what organizational
morphologies and what developmental
trajectories and ecosystems
of shared intelligence facilitate
adaptive cognition and what boards do
and how they both build on the legacy
and stay within that lane of what may be
legally required for compliance as well
as innovate and move beyond some of
these shortcomings and fallacies that
boards can fall into. Yeah, I've
actually looked into this a little bit
about how why boards are a thing. And
like, for example, a nonprofit boards,
they were just designed for a different
time when a lot of times you were just
getting basically foundations that had a
bunch of money that they were going to
allocate and they were like top down
driven models. Not necessarily
dynamically responding to the world
around them and dynamically changing.
And I think the law for profit
corporations, it was kind of like a
similar idea is like we are going to try
to this boat and we're going to go to
this other country and we're going to do
trade there and we're going to come
back. Right? It was a more simple and
linear model of thinking about planning
and so they're just made for a different
world. And I think now there's a lot of
legal infrastructure that has built up
around them. So actually innovating
around that is really difficult. So for
example, one thing. I've been working on
a nonprofit recently. We were like,
well, we don't want to have a board. We
want to be more community tripping. We
want to be a co op. And so then we look
into being co op. And actually the legal
infrastructure for setting it up is
actually just like, not developed at
all. You basically have to have a lawyer
spend thousands and thousands of dollars
to actually figure out how that's going
to work. And it's also very precarious
to even know if this thing is even going
to work. So it's just really this well,
trodden path has just been beaten down
over and over again because it's the
path of least resistance, but not
necessarily the optimal one for
cognition within the company or a
nonprofit. I was going to say earlier,
how did we get here to this board?
Right? And it's a script. It's a script
that has become solidified into law.
And it's the same thing, like when you
have a compliant board, like the rubber
stampers. And that's just also a script
that they have followed. So that's why
they're all compliant and not really
kind of leveraging the type of
governance that would be maybe optimal
for the strategy of the company.
Okay, cool. Yeah. Any other final
thoughts? Or we can hold it, table it
for the upcoming discussion.
Rhythms of Cognition, rhythms of the
Year. The agenda, setting the agenda.
Communicating with the board. Board
communicating with the organization.
Organization. Communicating outside the
organization. It's great
topics, and I think we're three
deep into the series, and we're just
going to continue to see how the
scholarship and the legacy of a
lot of conventional and even heterodox
thinking and management is taking the
next step with this book and the
contribution that takes it into the free
energy governance space.
Cool.
Well, thanks, guys, and we'll see you
next week for getting into the free
energy principle. All right, thank you.